[Music]  i  wanted to acquire more knowledge in  non-animal approaches  the topic was really relevant to my  everyday working activities  i wanted to expand my knowledge in the  area of free hours  [Music]  i particularly enjoyed position on eop  the program consists of lectures  small group discussion poster  presentation  lab tours and there's plenty of time for  networking and fun  expanded my network quite a lot and i'm  still in contact with  some of the friends that i made it led  me to a traineeship  with the jrc well i'm sure with this jrc  summer school on my resume  that's a great plus  i also sent one of my students already  there and i will continue to do so  i would highly highly recommend anyone  to participate  in the summer school of the grc good  luck with your applications  you